when we talk about max aerobic function
we're talking about heart rate as the
ultimate as the really important metric
here
so maintaining a particular heart rate
during the run
uh is that the measure that like how do
you know you're in the right
yeah yeah and then that's where it gets
a little tricky because like unless you
go into a lab and get your aerobic
threshold tested it's really hard to
have like an exact number on it
um you know dr phil maffetone with the
maximum function process
he'll say 180 minus your age is going to
give you your yeah that's the math 180
formula that i thought was
fascinating for it's like in the same
way e equals
e equals mc squared is fascinating that
there could be a formula that captures
like optimal running
yeah so that for people who don't know
that's 180 minus your age
if you train at that heart rate if you
run at that heart rate you're going to
progress a lot
and here's the advantage of that i think
like with any of these things you want
to look at it through
where are the advantages here and i need
to account for those and then where the
potential disadvantages
and then decide for me as an individual
do these advantages outweigh the
disadvantages
and what's the alternative approach and
is that going to produce more advantages
or less
so with with maximum function uh here's
some advantages like it is low enough
intensity
where you can train pretty consistently
at a fairly high volume
with a very low injury risk with uh
very low like things that are gonna
maybe lower your quality of life like
muscle damage and things like that
um it's a more efficient way in the
sense that you're going to be like
prioritizing like fat metabolization
which um i mean if you're looking at
like jeff folic and
or dr jeff folk and dr dominic de
agostino some of their research and
things
like that like they're going to show
that you know that's going to be a
little cleaner way to go about things
from just a recovery standpoint
a breakdown standpoint so they could be
like a what they call like a fat adapted
athlete so you can
go to your fat stores for energy if
you're
applying this matt what is it called by
the way math 180
is that is that a good is it what are
your thoughts about in general
for yourself and for the broader
population
i think the math 180 formula is about as
good of a
formula as you're gonna find in terms of
capturing as many people as you can get
away with capturing with a kind of a
universal thing
uh like any of these things i mean it's
it's more likely kind of on a bell curve
where
like the bulk of that 180 minus three is
probably going to be a pretty good at
least starting point to kind of figure
out where that is
there's some other things you can like
maybe use to kind of check it
that i like to do if i'm let's say i
just i did 180 minus my age i went out
and i started running and it was like
i'm running along and i'm just like my
my breathing is labored
i'm you know i'm struggling to get a
sentence out without gasping for breath
well that's my body telling me i'm
probably not actually at my true like
math number or my true or like
underneath my true aerobic threshold
like aerobic threshold and maximum
function you should be able to do that
for hours
and you should be able to breathe pretty
efficiently and talk yep carry a
conversation
um other people will say like you
another way to kind of gauge it if you
can breathe
in your nose and out your mouth that's
not necessarily the best way to do on a
from a performance standpoint but it can
be a good kind of
governor that will allow you to like if
you can if you can no longer breathe in
your nose and out your mouth you're
probably going too fast actually
technically be at your math pace or
under your math pace yeah i had a
actually when i was in in better shape
i had trouble getting to that math
number
i found myself like either i would be
doing way too much work
like it's too hard to do it was too hard
to get to that number i was running a
much
lower heart rate like 10 to 20 what do
you call that beats
lower and that's i was still for myself
happy with the pace it was good pace and
yeah and i just felt good
i was smiling and enjoying life and yeah
uh i did
and with the moment i take myself to
that uh level of like the
the math 180 level that's like
definitely like a real workout
yeah and it felt like i can't do that
for five ten fifteen miles
like i i started feeling it like this is
a one or two mile thing
no but i think his answer to that uh
i feel meth don't answer is maybe
you're supposed to like uh what
maybe do some more sprints or something
like that or build up your
maybe like i'm too weak yeah musculature
wise
to like uh yeah like that that's a sign
that you need to work on some stuff you
can't just keep enjoying life there's
there's two ways to look at that i think
and i think you're you're
you're right on i think that what the
advice from that
from that kind of a process would say is
either
you you're doing too much of it so it's
getting too hard for where your skeletal
muscle system is currently at
for that particular activity so like i
mean it can be different too like if
you're cycling versus running you know
that's a little bit of different
mechanic where it can be different where
you could take a super fit
cyclist and then put them on you know
the amount of volume they're going to be
able to tolerate relative to
what you're going to do when you remove
like impact forces and things like that
is going to be lower if they haven't
been practicing that activity so for you
like you know you're prioritizing like
uh
uh wrestling and mixed martial are not
mixed martial arts but jiu jitsu type
stuff so
uh you know running is maybe kind of
that
that uh that secondary activity versus
the primary activity
but yeah so what they would say is
probably like maybe instead of doing
that
at let's say you were doing that for
like 30 miles a week or something like
that and it was getting too hard to
continue
they'd say you know come back to 20 get
used to 20 get comfortable with 20.
then let's get you up to 25 and 30 and
kind of just like inch you along one of
the intuitions i had about
the ways i was failing at running is the
form was probably not great like
the way to get to those 30 40 miles
is to get the form right maybe i was
doing too big of steps not
so like playing with a different gate
playing with a different kind of
um the form kind of you have your form
the economy the efficiency yeah
so that was the intuition like i was
doing something wrong but i suppose
that's the benefit of these kind of
formulas it challenges you to think like
how can i improve this kind of stuff
well and it also it simplifies it so
much
that you're forced to right you're
forced to optimize within that
real strict parameter versus am i doing
my short intervals right
but my long run's wrong or am i doing my
like long intervals right but my short
intervals and
you just it kind of complicates things
when you start throwing a lot of stuff
there
and for most people especially when
they're first getting started you know
you're
you can't over complicate it or you're
just gonna like you're gonna do like a
bunch of half
right half wrong things and then not
really know where your progress or your
deficits are
necessarily at so i do think this is an
amazing approach
especially for people who are just
getting into it and building that
that foundation um where where i think
maybe you want to deviate from that a
little bit
especially when you start to get into
these events that are operating well
outside that intensity
so you take something like um you know
let's say
it's a race that takes you in the
neighborhood of around like 12 minutes
or something like that
then you're gonna be running
significantly faster than your your
maximum function pace
so most of the research is going to say
at some point in time you need to get
around to practicing the pace at which
you're going to perform at
and really fine-tuning the mechanics the
efficiencies
how it feels how to judge it how to pace
it at the pace
you're going to try to compete at so
there's obviously like a large range of
targets there when we talk about the
endurance world in general where
you know you have these shorter events
like five kilometers and then you also
have 100 mile races which are gonna
typically be quite a bit below your
maximum aerobic function and especially
on these trail races
you